who gets wifed up faster hoes or proots
wait explain
like a girl a girl that like waits or a
girl that sleeps with a guy right away
whoa who do you think it gets wifed up
faster
it really is a sticky one that's a good
question
someone that get um
a food someone awaits you think so yeah
i believe so because i feel like if
you're able
kind of does depend on the vibe but if
you're able to just like
slang it out so soon so quickly he might
not take you as seriously as someone
that's like more patient and would get
to know him
and kind of understanding better really
yeah let's hear from the guys i disagree
totally okay yeah you rather have
someone that would just no no
you don't have to slang it out no but
that was but no but it's like
there's a difference between that let's
say you make someone wait for a month
but whilst you're making me wait for a
month let's say i may just like lose
interest but you're making moves towards
like but she's just holding off i'm just
saying that as
not me but just like people
people they might like
lose interest in that because is that
all that like chasing and stuff like
that bro not everyone wants to do the
chasing stuff for so long but i mean you
can you chase say you chase you get it
what now imagine you chase for imagining
chase for a month and it's dead bro
[Applause]
okay and then what if you chase for a
month and it's good then you're chilling
but we could have been good
the next day um
all right cool maybe we're not you know
personally this is what 29 days so it's
basically it's based on the nine-day
rule
i don't know that's a bit of a sticky
one see because
on one hand i feel like guys do value
some sort of purity right and it's
biologically wired so they can't really
get rid of it but any guy like that
finds out his girl slept with a hundred
people probably wants to throw up
yeah yeah
okay i'll get a hug now
it has to you have to you know i mean
run a little bit and
you know flex a little bit but you can't
just you know because then you think our
next man could have had it easy like
that yeah so
it's just i guess there is a balance in
it because then you could go on a lit
first date and you guys could have sex
and then it could even be even better
but because you know the person you guys
are on the same vibe you kind of can
move forward from that but whereas like
do you know what i mean slang it out and
then you're done with that
yeah i feel like i feel like there is a
balance like
wait but don't slang out too early to
get it yeah but if you're gonna make
them wait don't make them wait too long
that just depends on who the guy is
there's some guys that don't mind they
can wait till marriage there's some guys
uh
[Laughter]
no but there are actually some guys that
can wait would want to wait but that
just depends on them yeah well that's
the thing that it just has to be
i feel like that just has to be a
balance between dinner
are you waiting until you're married
okay
i thought you you said you said okay
she said no
i like to have a little bit of fun you
know what i mean
someone in the comments it says it's not
biologically wired it is biologically
wired because over in history men have
to ensure paternity
so and the reason men prefer like a
lower body count is because historically
they had to ensure paternity
so um they had to make sure that they
weren't passing on resources to a kid
that wasn't theirs
because birth control changed the game
but that wasn't around historically and
even now there's some studies that say
up to like 20 percent of men are raising
a kid that's not theirs
it's crazy so would you guys do that
he's a kid that's not mine yeah
you'll fall in love with it yeah that's
hard it depends on what that sort of
situation with the goal like if i'm with
that it's not even just that it's not
even just if you're with them
if you've been with her
think about it think about it think
about it so so she told me she's
pregnant like two months pregnant
so for that seven months before the
baby's born
you've
grown to like adapt to like becoming a
man and then
you could be with a kid like four months
five months could be the first day you
love that baby
like find out that's not yours
your love for the baby is not gonna like
change it's gonna change for the girl
you're gonna hate the girl yeah
resentment every time you look at the
baby you could just be like damn
like i can't control it have you not
seen them them like judge shows where
they're having like them like they have
the test or you're the father you're not
the [ __ ]
and you see that like did the men just
break down
it
in
it broke but if she's had the kid
already and
would you guys do it then
yeah you have to collect for the ride i
mean the kid has to be young though if
you're 15.
that's long seven or 15 years
you know what's crazy about that like
the perception will probably change like
you know if you're like 40 50 unless
you're single
bro a lot of women that you're gonna
come
in contact with may have a kid bro
they're going to be 15 16 17 18
then it will change bro i mean yeah when
i get to that point it would change 15
hours loose bro we're like 20.
come on imagine i'm trying to imagine
trying to say you're not my dad oh
no but it's like when they're younger
yeah it'll be less it'll be a less
likely thing that they will say that
because yeah because they're young unit
that's probably
the first exactly
but they know that there's a that day
now someone's coming to now come like
take over
and then you've raised your voice at me
like are you my dad like you are you bro
i can't like that [ __ ] will burn bro
so wait would you guys date a single mom
so you you sounds like you wouldn't
whoa
oh do that hold on don't do that
i would
it depends though
really
like two months talking like intense
talking energy i'm saying like your
combo every day but okay you guys like
are you that desperate
like you could date a girl without kids
why on earth would you date a girl with
a kid actually
because because that's that one you're
raising you're putting your time
attention and resources into another
man's kid and she could break it off
with you tomorrow you put all this time
attention and resources and raising
someone else's kid you get nothing you
have no right a lot of resources
yeah it's just i mean i'm not paying
child support
if you live life like that you're not
gonna do anything yeah because you can
say that about the girl as a single like
i mean
she doesn't have a kid as well you put
all your time and results into that girl
for her to bring you off and cut yeah
bro
child don't know a child
you're getting married with no kids
yeah like i would oh my gosh i have
brothers if they brought home a girl
with a kid i would tell them to him to
dump her immediately
if if off the rip you told me you have a
kid be